翻訳: Riaki Poništ
校正: Moe Shoji
楽しい働き方のお話をしたいと思います
今日来てくださっている方で
会社にお勤めの方って
どのくらい いらっしゃいますか？
やっぱ多いですね
僕もそうです
あとは「会社で働いていたよ」
っていう方とか
あと「これから働くよ」
っていう方を合わせれば
もっと多くなるかなと思います
大体 皆さんって 会社で
どのくらい時間を過ごしているかって
お考えになったことってありますか？
１日８時間とか
７時間半とかですね
一生だと どのくらいでしょう？
学生さんが大学卒業して
それから定年まで勤め上げる
ということになると
８万時間を超えるぐらいの時間になります
８万時間って
かなり長い時間になりますよね
会社っていうのは
やっぱりそれだけ長い時間を過ごす
大事な居場所になります
そういった居場所がですね
突然失われてしまう
っていうこともあります
会社が倒産したり合併したり
リストラをしたり
ということがあった場合です
普通そういうのは あんまりないよって
思うかもしれませんけど
今 毎月700社ぐらいが倒産してます
結構な数になります
ちょっと前を思い出していただいて
リーマンショックって
憶えているでしょうか
あのときは 世界中で
かなりの数の会社が潰れました
ちなみにリーマンショックで
会社が潰れたり合併したり
リストラをされた人
（笑）
いらっしゃいますね
私もちょっと実は
それに近い人間です
あの時は本当に世界中
いっぱい会社が潰れて
そして人の居場所っていうのが
たくさん奪われました
2008年の暮れです
僕はその時 人のキャリアの
相談に乗って
就職をサポートする仕事をしていました
年の暮れから
ずいぶん たくさんの人が
毎日 相談に来ました
たいていが40代・50代の男性たち
世に言う「オジサン」たちですね
それまでは会社では
課長さんとか部長さんとか
そういうお役職で
かなりいろんな活躍をしてきた—
その会社の中では「スペシャリスト」と
言われるような方たちです
だけど ずーっとその会社で
頑張って働いてきた
そして会社が傾いて
リストラされてしまって
行き場所がなくなって
途方に暮れて僕のところに来ていた
箱の中に入って よそを知らなかった
「箱入りオジサン」だったんですね
急に困った顔をして
毎日 相談に来るんです
僕 その時20代で
社会人経験が非常に浅かったんで
50代のオジサンたちに
こういう人生相談
キャリアの相談をされるっていうのは
非常に大変だったんです
で オジサンたちが言うんですよね
「一生懸命 今まで
働いてきたんですけども
会社がこういうことになって
次の就職先がない
自分が何ができるかわからない
どうすればいいでしょうか」
って言われて
僕も「どうすりゃいいですかねぇ」
って一緒に悩んじゃってですね
「あなた 何がおできになるんですか」
って聞くと
「部長ができます・・・」
みたいな感じで
冗談みたいな話で
こういう業界ではある
笑い話なんですけど
本当にありまして
大手のメーカーの
グループ会社の部長さんでした
そんなこんなしてるうちに
僕も本当に会社というものがなくなって
要は会社が合併しまして
そこの仕事を続けられない
というふうなことになりました
幸いにして僕はその時に
自分で新規事業を組み立てていたので
それを持って よその会社に移る
というふうなことになりました
そこで僕自身はすごい
カルチャーギャップを味わいました
１社目の元々の会社が
流通サービスの会社だったんですね
流通サービスの会社っていうのは
新しさ 新しいものを提案して
作るということが一番大事です
で 面白そうだなと思ったら
「えいやっ」ってやってみて
走りながら考えるっていう社風です
値段の付け方は感覚的で
「大体このぐらいだろう」
みたいな市場感で付けて
やりながら調整していくんです
だから やたら利益率が高い
商品にできちゃったり
赤字の商品を売ってたり
とかするんですね
一方で ２社目のメーカー
これもう堅実さ重視です
新しさなんていらない
安全に長く続けることが大事
値段の付け方っていうのは
ひとつひとつ原価を
ものすごく細かく計算して
それを合算して
利益率を掛け合わせて値段にする
だから そんなに儲からないんですけど
損するってことはないんです
この２社 全く真逆の考え方で
そのギャップにすごく苦しんで
戸惑いました
事業の説明をする時に
流通サービスでずっとやってましたから
その考えで
「こんな新しい価値が生み出せます」
「こんなニーズがあります」とか
「こういうサービスは広がりがあります」
っていう話をするんですけど
それ メーカーの人には
全く通じないんですね
で 言われるんです
「あの原価計算って
どうなってるんですか」
「リスクは？」
「長く続けるためには？」
って言われます
一番 話が食い違ったのが
値段についてです
「積み上げで話をしてください」
って言われるんです
「稲葉さん 積み上げでお願いします」
でも 「積み上げ」って
全く ちょっと分かんなくて
何の専門用語かなって
ずっと思ってました
要は 難しい話じゃないんです
原価をひとつひとつ細かく計算して
それを積み上げていって合算する
その原価を
どういうふうに積み上げますか
それどうなってますか
っていうことなんですけど
僕 ずっと流通サービスの方にいたんで
分からないんですね
要は 文化が違う 違う箱の中に
入って生きていたものですから
よその箱の中の理屈って
全然分からなくて
苦しんだ というふうな経験をしました
幸いにして
メーカー側の理屈っていうのを
だんだん身につけていって
そこで 事業は無事に
スタートしたんですけども
このカルチャーギャップの経験って
すごくいい経験でした
何かやろうっていう時に
両方の視点
とても大事だと思うんですよね
新しいものをどういうふうに
作り出していけるのかって考えるのも大事
「えいやっ」って
走っちゃうのも大事ですけど
一方で きちっと長く続けるためには
どういうふうにしていくのかってことを
考えるのも大事です
で そういう２つの視点を
ここの まあ転職になるんでしょうか
そういったことをきっかけに
僕は身に付けられたので
ラッキーだったな
ってふうに思っています
こうやってリーマンショックの時の
おじさんの話と
僕のカルチャーギャップの話
２つ しましたけれども
何をお伝えしたいのかというと
「会社という １つの
箱の中に入っていないで
外に出てみませんか」ということです
１つの箱の中だけに入っていると
見えないことがいっぱいあります
外に出てしまえば
世界はぐっと広がります
新しい視点を手に入れることもできます
じゃあ どういうふうに
やればいいでしょう
社外の新しい視点を取り入れるためには
いくつか方法があります
例えば異業種交流会に行って
色んな会社の人の話を聞くこともアリでしょう
あと 転職しちゃう
なんていうのもありますね
だけど僕がお薦めしたいのは
この「ハイブリッドキャリア」
というものです
「ハイブリッド」という言葉は
最近 「ハイブリッドカー」とかで
聞くことがあると思います
異なる２つのものを混ぜ合わせて
新しい相乗効果を生み出す
というふうなことです
「パラレルキャリア」っていう
働き方については
聞いたことってあるでしょうか
会社の働き方ってのがあります
そして社外の活動があります
その２つが両立して並行して
パラレルに続けていくっていうふうなことが
パラレルキャリアなんですが
ハイブリッドキャリアは
そのパラレルキャリアをちょっと進化させて
その２つのものが相互に影響しあって
相乗効果を生み出していくよって
そういうふうな働き方のことです
これ 例えば異業種交流会に行くと
よその会社で働くってことが
できないんですね
聞くだけです
で 転職をしてしまうと
今の居場所を失って次に行くので
前の場所のことで何かやりたいと思っても
それは無理になります
ハイブリッドキャリアでは
今の居場所と他の活動を両立させる
大変さはありますけども
いいとこ取りをすることができます
僕自身ハイブリッドキャリアを
実践してます
会社の仕事では
人事サービスの企画をしています
まあ 人が働くということ
後は会社の人事とかというのに
新しい仕組みとか取り組みっていうのを
作っていって発信していくと
そういうふうな仕事です
社外では
２つの社会事業をやってます
１つは これ
「EDAYA」という活動 なんですが
フィリピンの山岳少数民族の人たちの
竹音楽の文化を
継承していこうというふうな活動で
それをアクセサリーにして
伝えています
もう１つが
「『エシカル男子の会』をつくる会」
という活動です
これは 男性の新しいあり方を
皆で持ち寄って発信していこうと
そういうふうな活動です
会社の仕事１つと社外活動２つ
３つの活動をしている
ハイブリッドキャリアなんですけども
非常に楽しい働き方であり
メリットがいろいろあります
例えばですね メリット
「人との縁」ってのがあります
会社の中での仕事 人の縁だけでは
限りがありますけど
社外で いろんなことをしていると
いろんな人と知り合います
そして一緒に何かをやるってことができます
で たまたまその中で
面白い働き方を実践していたり
研究していたりする人がいれば
これ 会社に持ち込んで
会社の中での仕事に紐づける
ということができます
後は「チャレンジ」
ということもあります
本業 人事に近い仕事をしているので
採用とか育成研修とか
チームビルディングとかですね
常に いろんな知識が
必要になってきます
経験値が大事です
だけど会社にいると そんなしょっちゅう
採用しているわけにいかないですし
育成ばっかりやってるわけにもいきません
新しい何かサービスがあっても
お試しでやるってのは ちょっと難しいんです
ただ 社外のEDAYAというところでは
自由にいろんな取り組みができるので
新しい採用の仕組み
みたいなのを取り入れて
どんどん自分の経験値ってのを
高めていくことができます
そのことは 会社に持ち込んで
持ち帰ってですね
新しいノウハウとして
人に伝えるっていうこともできます
こういうふうに社外の仕事が
会社の仕事にフィードバックをして
つながっていくってことになると
そもそもの会社の仕事も
非常に面白くなって充実してきますね
モチベーションが上がる
っていうことを感じます
そして後は「つなげて考える」
ということができるようになります
全然関係ないものを
並行したりしながらやってくので
何か関連性があって
相乗効果が生まれてくっていうことでの
いろんな発見ということです
例えば そのEDAYAというのは
さっき言ったように
フィリピンの少数民族の人たちの
文化をつなぐという
「エシカルファッション」と
言われる分野のアクセサリーです
これ人事の仕事と全然関係ないじゃん
って思う人が多いと思うんですが
結構つながってます
例えば そういうマイノリティの人たち
山岳少数民族の人たち
そのマイノリティの人たちが
いかに今の社会に対して
適合して生きていって
自己充足感みたいなものを味わって
活躍していくのかを考えるということは
人事の世界での
ダイバーシティを生かした組織作りとか
ということと全く同じテーマなんです
そういった 一見関係なさそうなものから
相乗効果を生み出して
自分の仕事に対しての
楽しさというものを増していけることが
このハイブリッドキャリアの
楽しさ 面白さ メリットだと思っています
でも「じゃあ どういうふうに
ハイブリッドキャリアを始めたらいいの？
NPOとか社会事業ってハードル高いよ」
って思う方って多いと思います
でも意外と 生活していると
身近に その種ってあるもんなんです
僕の知り合いの
おじさまの話なんですが
その方 奥さんがたまたま
土日出勤の仕事になったことをきっかけに
食料品とか生活用品を共同購入する集まりに
顔出すようになったんですね
どうしても女性が多い集まりなので
経理ができたり
会議体の運営ができたりするような
会社員の男性って
すごく重宝されまして
いつのまにか その会議体というか
集まりの中心メンバーになっていった
そこで いろんな
NPOの人たちと知り合って
たまたま その方の会社の仕事は
経営コンサルタントだったので
NPOの組織運営みたいなことを
アドバイスをしていって
今は社会事業家 社会起業家を
育成するような活動を
会社員をやりながらやっているとか
そういうふうな方もいます
いくつか そういう例は
ありますけれども
本当に こう見ていけば
日常の中に 意外と
そのきっかけはあるので
勇気を持って ちょっと顔を出してみる
というところから始めてください
さて こういった
ハイブリッドキャリアですが
働く人にとっては とても
いろいろなメリットがあると感じてますけど
会社にとっても
メリットがある働き方なんです
今 社会はものすごく
変化している時代です
会社も それに応じて
変わっていかなければ
生き残っていけません
そのために 社員に
ハイブリッドキャリアを推奨して
会社員の人たちが 外でいろんな
人脈とか知識とか経験とかを積んで
持ち帰ってきてくれれば
それを社内のリソースですね
いろんな自分たちの競争力
活力に変えるっていうことができます
だから いろんな企業さんも
このハイブリッドキャリアを
ぜひ推薦していただけたらなと
思うんですけども
「うちの会社はハイブリッドキャリア
推奨してますよ」って言っても
「じゃあ僕やります」って
言う社員さんがいるかというと
いないのが実情だと思います
そのための仕組みとして
「エクスターンシップ」っていうのを
考えてみたら
いいんじゃないかなと思います
エクスターンシップというのは
インターンシップの逆です
今いる社員さんを外に出して
社外の活動をしてもらって
戻ってきてもらうというふうな
取り組みになります
なので これから活躍してもらいたいな
っていうふうな社員さんを外に出して
社外活動を行なってきてもらって
ちゃんと戻ってきてもらう
というふうなことをしてもらえれば
会社の活力は
もっと増していくように思います
一部の会社でちょっと
取り入れられだしているんですけども
僕はこのエクスターンシップ
という仕組みを
もっと世の中に広めていきたいな
というふうに思っています
さて 最後になりますが
このハイブリッドキャリア
働く人にとっても会社にとっても
いい働き方ですけども
社会にとっても
いい働き方だと思います
世の中にとって一番貴重な財産
というのは「人」だと思います
さっきは「箱入りオジサン」なんて
言い方をしましたけれども
会社の中で ずっとしっかり
仕事をしてきて
その中でいろんな活動や知識や経験を
積んできた人というのは
本当に輝く
世の中の財産ですね
こういった人たちが
会社の中の 箱の中にいたんじゃ
本当に もったいない
世の中みんなで活用できるように
ならなきゃいけないというふうに思います
そのためにハイブリッドキャリアを活用して
会社の中だけじゃなくて
世の中のいろんな困りごとの中で
会社の中で蓄積した知識
というふうなものを生かして
あちこちをキラキラと
輝かせていただければ
いいんじゃないかなと思います
ハイブリッドキャリア
「三方よし」の働き方
これを実践してくれる人たちが
もっと増えることで
この世の中がもっと
明るく輝くような世界に
なればいいんじゃないかな
というふうに思います
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）